he's one of the top life and business
strategists in the nation he's helped
empower more than 50 million people in
over a hundred countries through his
audio video and coaching programs if you
want to learn about motivation you want
to learn from tony robbins mentor me
Tony
listen people ask me all the time if you
really want to get lasting change real
results that stick around what do you
got to do what are the most important
things you learned Tony in that area I
tell people the most common thing people
talk about is how they want to make a
change in their life but everybody wants
to change but nobody wants to work out
you know everybody wants a muscle but
nobody wants to train see one of the
challenges that we have in our lives is
we don't realize that the process of
training ourselves the process of
conditioning ourselves actually feels
incredible once you get that initial
momentum but most people don't why why
do somebody people say well I lost a
hundred pounds you know the same ten
pounds ten times
or they'll tell me you know I'm on my
fourth day without a cigarette man I'm
doing really good if you're counting the
days it's not lasting change you just
count the days you can tell people how
long you last it if you want lasting
change you've got to give up this idea
of trying something you get aside you're
gonna commit to mastering this here's
what leaders really do they maximize
resources a leader can come into an
organization that's totally torn up in
horrible shape take the same resources
take it to another level your body your
mind your emotion but you can't maximize
it when you're trying to fit in if you
can't maximize it when you live by
everybody elses rules I'm not saying
don't be respectful I'm just saying as a
leader you got to decide what you
believe is right and one thing I can
tell you will always feel right to never
settle for less than you can be do share
or give that will feel right
our whole life is shaped by decisions
that's what we talked about today right
but there's three decisions you're
making every moment you're alive and the
way you make these three decisions
shapes your destiny first decision we're
all making every moment is what are you
gonna focus on what are you gonna focus
on and you know I realized that my
father's life and my wife ended up very
different because we made that day three
decisions very differently he decided to
focus on the fact that he has not fed
his family and the second question you
gotta decide every moment you're alive
including this moment what are you to
focus on second question is as you're
focusing on what does this mean what
does it mean and the bottom line on
meaning is if you think about it you get
to make up the meaning and most people
pick the worst one don't pay that day my
father decided to focus lavake Adam fed
his family and I know what meaning he
gave cuz he sent it out loud over and
over again that he was worthless because
he had not taken care of his family and
then the final most important decision
you make every moment you're alive what
am I gonna do what am I gonna do and
I'll tell you we just had to do he
decided to leave our family shortly
thereafter which at the time was it was
the worst experience of my life it was
the most crushing experience I felt
that's been so many years now I don't
have the same feelings and part of it as
three years ago he passed away but at
the time I knew no greater pain my
family did no greater pain I couldn't
understand why I would leave I loved him
so much and my wife turned out very
different than him I was the only one to
go to his funeral no one else in the
family would go nobody want to be part
of it he died alone of a disease called
connective tissue disorder and I can
tell you right before his death he got
the lesson cuz he looked at me he said
son he said I was a bastard I didn't
connect with anybody and look what I'm
dying of it's unbelievable everything
you people have told me I didn't have
the technology I don't have the right
contacts I didn't have the time I didn't
have money everything you've told me I
didn't have enough Supreme Court
justices
those are resources and so you're
telling me I fail because I didn't have
the resources and I'm here to tell you
what you already know resources are
never the problem it's a lack of
resourcefulness is why you failed
because the ultimate resources are
emotional states if you're creative
enough can you find the answer yes or no
if you're determined enough can you find
the breakthrough yes or no if you're
passionate loving enough can you get
someone to help you yes or no if there's
no way that you're committed can you
find the money even if you don't have it
yes or no
so I said creativity decisiveness
passion honesty sincerity love these are
the ultimate human resources and when
you engage these resource you can get
any other resource on earth and I said
so you told me all the resources you're
missing and you hypnotize yourself into
believing that you don't have what you
want because you don't have the
resources when the most successful
people in history have no resources but
they were incredibly resourceful so they
got the resources resourcefulness is the
ultimate resource and if you don't have
what you want stop telling yourself the
story because you don't the money all
the time that's [ __ ] it's because
you haven't committed yourself where you
would burn your boats if you want to
take the [ __ ] island burn your
[ __ ] boats and you will take the
island because people when they're gonna
either die or succeed tend to succeed
but most of us give ourselves a way out
and that's why we don't have what we
want
here's what I've created for my life and
anyone who knows succeeded I'm a 17 year
old kid from Azusa California with no
real education other than self education
with no background with parents that did
their best all of them with no money but
I did one thing I love people and I had
an enormous demand I made upon myself
and I sculpted my mind and my emotions
to get me to do whatever it would take
to achieve and to contribute but to do
that I did it by using my body and
changing my focus I did it by putting
myself in a peak physiology and using
what I call incantations can you train
yourself to believe something yes or no
absolutely how many have ever made the
fatal mistake of
going to Disneyland or Disney World and
while you're there made the fatal
mistake of going to a ride called it's a
small world after all
what happens for about a week after
you're out of that damn place you're
still singing this thing in your head
and 24 languages right let me tell you
something how many of you have things
when you want to go Chiba man this part
of your voice goes oh it's not gonna
happen or forget it
I'm gonna go to voices sometimes
interrupts that good pattern say what
you want to do is train a new one so
starting when I was 17 I started doing
incantations not affirmations
affirmation you go on a p.m. at the
event the event p.m. happy what's the
problem you haven't changed your what
your what physiology if you don't change
your physiology you won't get anything
so in incantations you only you speak it
but you embody what you're saying with
all the intensity you can and you do it
with enough repetitions that it sticks
in your head like it's a small world now
the conversation your head is always the
same and it gives you what you want so
use your body and your voice so 17 years
ago I started doing things I was working
for Jim Rohn this speaker when I was 17
years old I had long hair minestrone
soup acne on my face I was trying to
call on Bear Stearns type of people and
convince them why they should go to this
man seminar be more successful I was
driving a 1968 Volkswagen that I had
earned at $40 a week as a janitor the
only way I did it was parked far from
the building and then go in and I love
people I believe and I put myself in
state and I was able to influence people
that were far more successful I was at
the time I will do something that I
still do backstage and have done for 23
years
because I don't hope I'm gonna be in a
good State I demand it so I do an
incantation using my whole body that's a
command my subconscious mind to direct
me and helping as many people's possible
life today to better their lives they
gave me the strength the emotion the
persuasion the humor the brevity
whatever it takes
you surely feel and get these people to
change their lives now I would do that
literally driving in my Volkswagen to a
meeting in LA on the freeway for 40
minutes people are looking I'm screaming
to pop my lungs they're going I know
he's a serial killer I know he is
but by the time I entered that room when
two people meet if there's rapport the
person who's most certain will always
influence the other person and I was
probably certain and they were trying to
get revved up to certainty do you agree
with this yes or no I do another one
because I was poor I changed my mindset
I kept doing things but I never got
beyond it
I'd say God's love this circulating in
my life as well flows to me an
avalanches of abundance all my needs
desires and goals are met
instantaneously by infinite intelligence
for I'm one with God and God's
everything and I would imagine the
abundance of my life and I would feel so
grateful yeah you're like one for making
thirty-eight thousand dollars a year to
make a million dollars a year in one
year today people get injured today they
don't get injured smashing in the people
playing football nothing else to get
into you're typing you know picking up a
pencil oh oh they're really oh that's
some people can hurt today because we
don't use everything anymore we live in
the box think about it think about our
lives today and how different it is that
may be the way we are form do you main
to run to hide to create to procreate to
raise our children to move to form to do
all the things that made us use all of
our body today what do we do you wake up
and you have this box life you have a
box breakfast right you get your box car
you drive your box office you float up a
box elevator you don't use the stairs of
course right you go to your box office
where you type on a box talk on a box
right go into a box room for meetings
right sure enough got a little box you
can type on listen to this in a music
gun box have your box lunch drive your
box home or get in the train or subway
and another box home get home to your
box and then turn on the box
type on a box messaging on a box I mean
and maybe go get a cylinder to change
your state maybe and most people's idea
of exercise in our society today is fill
the tub pull the plug and fight the
current but that's not the world we live
in today Michael Gerber the guy that
wrote the e-myth you know talks about
why so many businesses young businesses
fail and one of these things he says is
most people are not really entrepreneurs
but they think that's what they should
be they think that's the sexy thing
that's the most attractive thing that's
the best answer and what I say to you is
you've got to separate the vehicle from
the outcome what is it that's gonna
truly fulfill you what is it that's
gonna give you that extraordinary life
what's gonna make things magnificent on
your terms not somebody else's terms not
your father your mother your background
what is that really separate the vehicle
there's many ways to get to that vehicle
what I'm saying sometimes you got to
reevaluate what's gonna really make you
fulfill what is your gift are you an
artist are you the talent can produce
something no one else produces as a
skill or a product or a service or some
impact are you incredibly good at
management you really know how to manage
or lead people are you an extraordinary
entrepreneur that has can take that
gigantic gut load of risk and can create
the vision and attract the talent that
you need and the managers and leaders
you may have all three abilities but
which one really fulfills you the most
is gonna be the critical question
because we tend to want to do them all
especially room like this because you're
all overachievers right me too and you
say oh I can do all these yes you can
but what will it do to your quality of
life see again the secrets gonna be this
what is an extraordinary life on your
terms today getting clear about that at
this stage of life where you are where
you want to go and when you think in
terms of outcomes and that activities
pretty soon some of the activities and
ulis you'll need me to do to get the
outcome you find a better way you get
the outcome quicker now how do you do
that yes three questions question one
what is my result was my outcome what is
that I really truly want from this if
you're going back next
week he said this next week one of the
most important what outcomes for me to
get this week in my business he is right
those outcomes out not your action items
the outcomes you if you do that nothing
else you'll be ahead of the game if you
just keep looking those outcomes every
day how am i doing on that outcome your
brain will come up with ways to get to
that outcome I promise you focus on the
outcomes not on activities action for
most people activities most people may
mistake movement for achievement they
mistake action items into dues for
achievement we're after the achievement
are you with me on this yes or no it's a
different way of thinking and I think
all of you inherently have it but if you
make this ritualize just like the things
you've learned this week they're all
great but if you don't systematize them
they'll work when you do them but if you
systematize them right and you see like
mr. Holloman here where he goes in and
just does it and does it make sure it's
being done again or what you've seen
chat do or what I do you just do it over
and over again you don't miss it now the
results are geometric so I'm gonna get
you systematize the thinking whether you
do it visually the way I'm gonna show
you or not
so first question what's the result from
after what's the ultimate result what I
want out of this week out of this thing
out of my business out of my life out
for my body and you want to be as what
is possible when you describe that
outcome that result as what as clear and
specific as possible generalities will
confuse you whenever you don't learn
it's because someone is trying to teach
you in a different way
and the different way is I was a good
student in school I like learning until
I got junior high school high school
where I ain't liked all subjects until I
got to there when math became algebra
geometry and trigonometry cuz when I got
there I totally hated it so I had no
motivation to really learn it and with
no drive to learn something you know but
then secondly since I wasn't driven it
was also the class that usually had the
most homework and if you didn't in the
homework and you came in the next day it
was like being in a foreign language
class hypotenuse Yvette's
I see over and all I'm hearing is
hahahaha oh yeah my drain searching oh
don't know what that is so then I would
raise my hand to ask a question she's
not a good thing to do in that
environment so I'd say well what is the
hypotenuse will be die and they go all
our supa dupa dupa you don't know that's
really like I Papa died but I bet you
don't know so if you want to learn
something if you're not learning it's
not that you're not smart it's not that
you can't figure it out
it's that the person is explaining it
using references you don't have so I've
learned things like quantum physics I've
learned things like nuclear power from
physicists I'll say okay explain to me
how that's like an orange right how's
that least like a solar system something
I understand
and sure enough once they make that
linkage you got it you understand the
relationship you understand what things
are life will pay whatever price you ask
of it you know what's interesting
you got to ask intelligently in the
Bible it says ask and you shall what
yeah pretty good formula you gotta look
into it but you know what this is asking
you shall receive but I'm sure it meant
ask intelligently I'm sure that's what
God meant I'm sure you didn't mean [ __ ]
and you will receive wine and you will
receive I don't think that was the
instruction now if you're gonna ask
intelligently there might be five
elements of that number one you'd have
to ask specifically wouldn't you you'd
ask in a general way people do almost
anything I want more money fine here's a
dollar get out of here very often you're
getting what you're asking for you're
just not aware of how general you're
asking clarity is power the more clear
you are about exactly what it is you
want the more your brain knows how to
get there
your brain is a servomechanism it's like
a bomb those bombs those missiles they
have a servomechanism so if the target
moves it knows what the target is it
follows it your brain when you condition
it knows exactly what to go for it will
find a way to get there do you ever buy
a certain outfit or a certain car and
suddenly see that car outfit everywhere
how many had that experience say I how
come that car outfits everywhere it
always was everywhere but now you notice
it and the reason because there's a part
of your brain called the reticular
activating system the RAS that
your brain determines what you notice
and what you don't notice your brain
spends most of its time trying to make
sure you don't notice because you'll go
crazy if you notice everything but when
you decide what's most important to you
your brain goes after it
everyone I know successful have builds
what I call an RPM plan and RPM is built
on the metaphor that the way to get from
where you are to where do you want to go
to the fastest is you got to build power
like at a car RPMs and the R stands for
they know the result they're after they
know what they want precisely if you
don't know exactly what you want or you
let yourself get beyond that into
something general you're not gonna
achieve it clarity is power you gotta
know the specific result you have to
what do you want if you can't answer
that question right now in your personal
life in your body in your relationships
and your finances and your spirituality
then you're not going to be as so filled
as you want to be today we're gonna have
you answer one of those questions at
least the second part of that you got to
know P why you're doing it because you
know what you're making a big goal
suppose I want to make a billion dollars
I want to bring peace to the earth why
cuz soon as you come over the goal all
the obstacles show up unless you got
enough emotional drive to break through
that you're never gonna discover what it
really takes so you got to get yourself
past that no way to get past that us
have enough reasons reasons come first
answers come second this man did not
know what he wanted to do not have
enough reasons to ask intelligently you
gotta have specifically to ask
intelligent you gotta know why you
wanted have enough drive to make it
happen enough juice to make it happen if
you don't have enough reasons you will
not make it happen and the M is what is
your massive action plan what is gonna
get you to actually fall through because
the first plans not gonna work and the
second one's going to work so you better
have enough plans that the first two
don't work you still got something else
otherwise you're gonna be having excuses
where I didn't work so asking
intelligently requires that so if we're
gonna be extraordinary in our results we
got them in an extraordinary state we're
gonna know what we want we gotta go use
it thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know which
of the clips was the most motivating to
you and why leaving the comments below
I'm gonna join the discussion thank you
for watching and team to believe and
I'll see you soon